it's time for this week's pet project
lori herron joins us from nspca
and this is the time of year lawyer
where parents may be considering giving
a pet
for christmas and it's great because
it's exciting when you open it up at the
end of the day
when christmas is over there's a new
member of the family to take care of so
there's some responsibility to talk
about
you're right kendall this is the time of
the year where
the idea of a kitten like
boo here who i have to say is not
available for adoption boo
is my foster kitten who already has an
adoptive home
or a puppy or a dog or a cat or
one of the other many small pets we have
at nevada spca
and we advise first of all that if you
to
whomever you're going to um give a pet
as
a gift for the holidays make sure that
recipient really wants the pet and it's
not just
your idea of of your wanting that
recipient to have the pet
and then secondly of course parents want
to give that pet to their children
and we advise that while it's wonderful
it is a huge commitment and a
responsibility
and you need to be prepared that you're
the one that's going to be taking care
of that animal because
i don't know about you with your kids
kendall but
all my children's dogs and cats i was
the one taking care of them despite
conversations where they promised
they would do everything they they take
care of everything and that rarely
happens right
absolutely in fact so boo here has been
adopted by
a home with three little girls happens
to be my stepdaughter's home
and she's prepared to do all of the work
as they learn the responsibilities
because
that's just the way it works and we want
to make sure that the pet is in good
hands and the adults need to
assume that responsibility if they're
giving the pets to their children for
the holidays yeah you don't want to give
away the present but it is good to have
some conversations ahead of time right
absolutely all right lori it is so good
to talk to you as always
i hope everybody has a wonderful holiday
season and if you do get a pet
that it's a wonderful wonderful gift to
your family
thanks kendall happy holidays you too if
you're interested in adopting a pet you
can just go to nevadaspca.org
call them at that phone number
if you want to set up an 702-873-7722 to
go visit a pet